اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
بانوراما نناقش فيها ثلاث ملفات لهذا
المساوا في العناوين
[موسيقى]
يفجر غضبه على الحزب الديمقراطي ويتهمه
بتدمير البلاد فهل سيقرب التصعيد مع
الديمقراطينا تراك من البيت الابيض ام
سيصعب عليه السباق الرئاسي
الرئيس الفرنسي في زياره دوله للصين
الاقتصاد واوكرانيا على جدول اعمال
الزياره هل ستغلب كفه الاقتصاد كفه الحرب
وفيروس ماربر ينتشر في افريقيا فهل يتحول
الى جائحه عالميه ولماذا عادت الفيروسات
تقدر النائمه منذ سنوات طويله لتفتك
بالبشر الجديد
احييكم الى تفاصيل الملف الاول بعد نحو
سبع ساعات من مغادرته محكمه من هاتنويورك
حيث دفع بانه غير مذنب عن 34 تهمه ثنائيه
وجهها المدعون ضده الرئيس الامريكي السابق
والمتهم دونالد ترامب تحدث من منتجعه
الخاص بفلوريدا في خطاب تجاوز العشرين
دقيقه حضره انصاره من الحزب الجمهوري
وتابعه الملايين عبر العالم ترامب الهاضب
اولا دفع ببراءته ثم فتح النار على
الديمقراطيين جل الخطاب كان موجها لهم
اتهامات مباشره مؤكدا انه ضحيه حمله
مطارده نظمها الديمقراطيون ترامب قال ان
الديمقراطين هجموا بشكل شخصي وحاولوا
النيل منه بتحقيقات زائفه كما قال لا اساس
لها من الصحه واتهمهم بمحاوله تدمير
الولايات المتحده وبانهم يحاولون منذ فوزه
برئاسه نيله منه بشكل شخصي كما اتهم هم
باستغلال القضاء الامريكي لمنعي ترشحه
الانتخابات
20420 ترامب لم يكتفي بخطابه غريب جدد
هجومه اليوم ايضا واعتبر في تعليق عبر
منصه سوشيلتروس ان ما فعله الحزب
الديمقراطي لم تشهده البلاد من قبل في
اشاره الى تاسيس المحاكمه ولائحه الاتهام
التي وجهت له في محكمه منهتن
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كذلك ايهاب عباس المحلل السياسي اهلا بكم
ضيوف الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا معك استاذ
ايهاب في الواقع هذه التصريحة التي يقول
البعض بان ترامب صعد من خلالها هجومها على
الديمقراطيين وكانها فتحت الباب مبكرا
للانتخابات التمهيديه وكاننا بيتنا امام
تنافس واضح وتصريحات معلنه هل هي انتخابات
ما قبل الانتخابات تعتقد
نعم اهلا بحضرتك استاذه ريم واهلا
بالدكتور عيد وبكل المشاهدين اينما كانوا
بكل تاكيد نحن في صراع سياسي وحاله
استقطاب شديده يشهدها المجتمع الامريكي مع
طبعا
مشاهدناه بالامس من بدايه جوله المحاكمه
في صورتها الهجرائيه الاوليه وبعد ذلك
الغضب الكبير الذي صبه الرئيس السابق
دوماند ترامب على الديمقراطيين وعلى
المدعي العام حتى على القاضي نفسه عندما
تحدث عن علاقه ابنته بكماله حارس ابنه
القاضي وتحدث عن جو بايدن وهنتر بايدن وكل
هؤلاء
ويعني حفز الامريكيين من محبيه طبعا
الذين يرون في خطابه الشعبوي دائما نصره
لهم وقدره على جذبهم حوله فيما يتعلق
برؤيته المستقبليه لامريكا هؤلاء ايضا
كانوا قد اختبروه في اربع سنوات عندما كان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ويعتقدون انه
هو الافضل لقيادتها في الوقت الراهن وانه
ظلم طبعا في الانتخابات السابقه بكل تاكيد
الدعايه الانتخابيه للرئيس دونالد ترامب
بالامس كانت في اوجها وفي اقل من 24 ساعه
يعني جمعت حملته الانتخابيه خمسه ملايين
دولار هذا يدل على ان هناك التفاف واصطفاف
كبير حوله من جانب المواطنين الامريكيين
ويعني ايضا انه ربما في المقابل سنشاهد
حاله استقطاب اخرى من قبل الديمقراطيين
وسنكون امام حرب كلاميه كبيره خلال الفتره
القادمه بين المعسكرين الديمقراطي
والجمهوريه ان انقل هذا السؤال دكتور
أضمان دكتور ادمان هل في مقابل تصريحات
ترامب سنشهد كذلك عمليه استقطاب من
الديمقراطيين كما تفضل بالاشاره الاستاذ
ايهاب بمعنى انه سنكون كذلك امام تصريحات
اخرى امام اتهامات اخرى موجهه من
الديمقراطي لترام
تحياتي لك
من الواضحه ان حاله الاستقطاب التي اشار
اليها الاستاذ ايهاب هي فعلا
تعبر وتعكس الوضع في الولايات المتحده
هناك انقسام حاد ولذلك بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين ولذلك اتوقعك باننا سنرى
المزيد من القصائد من قبل الجانبين
الجمهوري والديمقراطي سنرى الاستمرار في
الاتهامات الديمقراطيه للرئيس ترامب
اتهامه بارتكاب جرائم ارتياب اتهامه بانه
هو كان مسؤول عن حوادث سته يناير عندما
حدثت هجوم على الكونغرس الامريكي وانه هو
الذي خرب مصداقيه وسمعه للولايات المتحده
وانه يميني متطرف انه يهدد الديمقراطيه في
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي فان هذه ستستمر
وهذه النغمه سترتفع ولكن في نفس الوقت
ايضا سنرى الاستمرار من قبل الجمه حتى
الان يبدو ان الجمهوريين وان ترامب ايضا
سيحاول استغلال هذه المحاكمه
والاتهامات التي وجهت له في في محكمه
نيويورك
لصالحه انتخابيا وهناك طبعا ثلاث دعاوى
اخرى ومن المؤشرات على انه حتى الان يبدو
ان ترامب قد حصل على دعم اكبر ربما ما كان
يتوقعه
خصومه الديمقراطيين انه جمع حتى الان ليس
فقط خمس ملايين بل عشر ملايين دولار
احتلال الايام الاربعه
على الاقل على هذا المستوى ولكن تحدثت عن
التفاف الجمهوريين حول ترامبونا سؤال
استاذ ايهاب هل تعتقد بان تكاتف
الجمهوريين تكاتف الحزب الجمهوري هو مقتصر
فقط على هذه القضيه بمعنى انه هناك
شخص ينتمي لنا فنقف معه في مثل هكذا نحن
او ان التف اف الجمهوريين قد يستمر الى
حدود او الى مستويات اخرى
يعني الفكره الجمهوري لا يتوقف فقط عند
دعم الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب لماذا لان
هناك اختلاف في الايدولوجيه وفي الافكار
بين الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي وفي هذا
التوقيت تحديدا هناك فيما يبدو رؤيه
جمهوريه بانه يجب تقديم الدعم الكامل
لدولار لانه في النهايه سينعكس على الحزب
بالايجاب لذلك شاهدنا ان كثير من قيادات
الحزب على المستوى الكبير ومن بينهم حتى
المرشحون
لخوض سباقه الانتخابات التمهيديه في الحزب
الترشح للانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
المقبله
كارونديس حاكم فلوريدا ونيكي هيلي واخرون
يقفون بجوار دونالد ترامبو يدافعون عنه لا
اعتقد انهم يدافعون عنه للشخصي فقط ولكن
يعلمون انهم يعني اكلتم يوم اكل الثور
الابيض وترامب اليوم هو الثور الابيض ومن
الممكن ان يتحول هؤلاء في اي لحظه من
اللحظات الى ثيران بيضاء ايضا يتم نحرهم
على
بمعنى ان هناك استهداف للحزب الجمهوري هم
يرون بان هناك استهداف لجمهوريين وبالتالي
عليهم التحرك رغم انه كانت هناك تصريحات
ملفته يعني نشير مثلا الى ان سنتر
الجمهوريه ونحن سنتابع هذه التغريده سنه
الجمهوريه في بيان كان نشره على تويتر قال
ان شخصيه وسلوك ترامب جعل منه شخصا غير
مناسب لموقع رئاسه وكان شدد الا احد فوق
القانون ولا حتى رؤساء السابقين ولكن لكل
فرد الحق في معامله متساويه بموجب القانون
دكتور ادموند ان يكون هناك تازر تكاتف على
مستوى هذه القضيه ولكن يقول بانه في
النهايه يمكن ان نقف معه ولكنه ليس مناسب
لرئاسه هل هذا يعبر عن وجهه نظر الجمهوريه
تعتقد او فقط يخص ميت رومني
لا لا اولا كان من اقصى النقاط دونالد
ترامب صوت مرتين
لعزله عندما كانت محاولات العزل عندما كان
ترامب اولا عندما كان لا يزال في السلطه
وبعد ان
فشل في الانتخابات
وبالتالي فان رامنه هو من الخصوم
الشرسين لترامب ولكنه على الرغم من ذلك
فانه وقف الى جانبه واتهم
المحكمه بانها مسيسه اتهم القضاء بانه
مسيس وبالتالي عندما نسمع حتى من شخص مثل
رامنه مثل هذا الدعم هذا يظهر بان القضيه
هي اكبر من ذلك لماذا هي اكبر من ذلك لان
هناك الان بدانا نرى بان من يهدد
ديمقراطيه على الاقل هذا ما نسمعه من
الجمهوريين
من انصار ترامب وليس فقط من انصاره بل من
ايضا تيار اوسع وحتى بعد خصومه السياسيه
حكومه الامريكيه بدات
تستغل او الاداره الامريكيه بالاحرى مرات
تستغل القانون
لملاحقات خصومها السياسيه وهذه مساله خطره
يقول هؤلاء انا تهدد الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه لان في الولايات المتحده هناك
توازن بين السلطات هناك القضاء يجب ان
يكون مستقلا تماما بين الذراعين
التشريعي
وحضرتك لا تراه مستقل في هذه الاسنان
دكتور هذا ما بدانا نراه فعلا الان هو ما
يقوله الكثيرون ان له خاصه الخبراء
القانونيين انا القانون يجب ان يكون اعمى
ولكن هذه المره منذ 2016 بدانا نرى بان
القانون على الاقل في تعاملهم مع ترامب لم
يعد اعمى هذا على الرغم من ان ترامب لديه
اخطائه الكبيره هو يتكلم بلهجه غير سياسيه
غير دبلوماسيه وهو دائما مشاكس
ويشكل الكثير من يعني
الوجع الراس هو محل جدل بتصريحاته بافعاله
ولكن ما تطرحه دكتور ادمان يمكن اعتباره
خطير لما تتحدث عن تاثير السياسه في
القانون يعني الخلط بين سلط يعني موت
الديمقراطيه استاذ ايهاب هل وصلنا الى حد
التشكيك في مثل هكذا مبدا داخل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
للاسف الشديد نعم وهذا التشكيك ليس حديثا
هو فقط اليوم ربما في ازهى صوره واكثرها
فجاجه لكن هو موجود منذ فتره خاصه في
العمل يعني اندماج العمل السياسي بالعمل
القضائي واستغلال السلطه السياسيه للسلطه
القضائيه في تصفيه حسابات او في تحديد
سياسيين على على المستويات العمل السياسي
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه هذا
للاسف الشديد بالفعل موجود وهناك حتى قضاه
يعبرون صراحه عن انتماءاتهم سواء كانت
الديمقراطيه او جمهوريه وهذا لا ينفي
لا ينفي ان الجمهوريين بدورهم ايضا في
مرحله من المراحل يستغلون القانون
ويحاولون ان يطوعونه والقضاء لمصلحتهم
ونذكر انه في فتره حكم الرئيس السابق
دونالد ترامب حرص على تعيين اعضاء جدد في
المحكمه العليا في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه انتماءاتهم كانت جمهوريه ايضا
يعني للاسف الش القضاء من الممكن ان يسيس
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ولا يوجد
من يحميه على اقل تقدير في هذا التوقيت
الحرج والحساس للبلاد صحيح وفي هذا الاطار
ترامب كذلك
تصريحاته لم تخلو من اتهام وزارات العدل
المدعي العام الى اخره وكانت هناك تصريحات
قويه في هذا الاطار دكتور ادمود هل تعتقد
بان هذه القضيه وهي قضيه تاريخيه نحن
نتحدث عن اول رئيس سابق امريكي اعتبر
معتقلا وقدم صوره جنائيه قدم البصمات يعني
حتى التفاصيل سابقه داخل الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هل تعتقد بانه هذه القضيه قد
تؤثر كذلك على المؤسسات القضائيه
[موسيقى]
الجنحه الى مستوى الجنايه او الجريمه وهذا
يعتبر تسييس وحتى الان لم يقدم ادله كافيه
لبل انه قرر 34 مره تقريبا نفس التهم دون
ان يقدم ادله طبعا سيطالبه المحامون
بتقديم هذه الادله واعتقد انه في النهايه
سيضطر الى تقديم اي ادله موجوده لدي ولكن
الطريقه التي يتم التعامل بها وهذه قد
بدات تجلب بعض التعاطف لترامب على الرغم
حتى من بعض منتقديه داخل الحزب الجمهوري
وهذه المره اراك متعاطف معه
مره نقول هنا على قلب بالنسبه للشخصيه من
المستقلين واستطيع ان اقول بانني لم اصوت
له في اي من الانتخابات اما 22 20 او 16
ولكن هنا اعتقد ان القضيه هي اعمق من ذلك
القضيه
امريكا نفسها
وهذا ملف اخر قد نتابعه كذلك بنقاش ولكن
في حلقه اخرى يبدو باننا دخلنا في اولى
خطوات الانتخابات التمهيديه مبكر مبكر جدا
سنتابع كل ذلكم الجزيل الشكر من واشنطن
الدكتور غريب استاذ العلاقات الدوليه كذلك
جزيل الشكر لحضرتك ايهاب عباس المحلل
الاساسي شكرا لكما